[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's trey lance of my north dakota state
bison it's not bison's it's bison
and he joins us behalf of uh old spice
committed to helping guys build
confidence and empowering them to reach
their full potential
and you can learn more about how to help
big sisters of america
help draft the next generation of
mentors and uh more than
30 000 youth waiting to be matched up
with a big
at bigdraft21.com trey lance joining us
on the program
trey good morning thanks for joining us
uh i know you got a brother who's a
pretty good football player your dad was
a pretty good football player
how good was that how how much does dad
tell you about how good dad was
thank you for having me first i guess
i've been a fan of the show for a really
long time
this is exciting uh my dad he'll he'll
put on the tape the vcr
tape um we actually have a old little tv
that
his vcr tape got stuck in uh and he
he refuses to throw the team away
because the highlight tape is in there
so he played uh small college southwest
missouri state
and then he was he went to the oilers
the niners
and then he played what canadian
football league yes sir yes we played
the southwest minnesota state it's in
marshall minnesota where i grew up uh
yeah oilers 49ers uh saskatchewan rough
riders in the cfl and then london
monarchs
oh london monarchs now you could follow
your dad and end up with the 49ers
that is i understand that
[Laughter]
are you sweating do you need some old
spice there um
okay okay you don't have to tell me
where you're going
but do you know where you're going i
honestly do not
and i wish i did i wish i could be like
you know i know but i'm not gonna tell
you i wish i could tell you that right
now
okay because we keep hearing the niners
aren't sure about mac jones and you
what have the niners told you um
just about the same thing as everyone
else honestly uh not a whole lot i've
just
just gotten to know me i had zooms and
obviously
got to know football but that's about it
if you could ask the niners a question
what would you ask
i would ask them if they're going to
drive me
your favorite team growing up was who
never was a die-hard i guess nfl guy at
all
um but vikings i was you know minnesota
guys growing up so like ap
brett favre those days were uh the prime
for me
who plays the position the way you do
like former quarterback is there
somebody that you look at and say
that's who i modeled my game after i
tried to to put myself in the box of one
guy
just because anyone i'm gonna say has
obviously done really really well in the
league
um for me obviously i watch a ton of
football watches on the quarterbacks
i watch uh russell willis and dad you
know desean carson
uh those are probably some of the
biggest ones that i watch uh but yeah i
try not to you know i'll leave it to you
to give me the
comparison i don't know if there is a
comparison i
like i always get nervous when we try to
compare because
you know you start to look at somebody
physically i i don't know what you're
like mentally
other than what somebody has told me
that you're very bright
not just football bright um but you know
you got a sense of humor you're not
afraid of contact
you know that they were trying to make
you a defensive back or a linebacker
isn't that crazy though when you look
back you could be a top five pick and
somebody wanted to make you a linebacker
or a defensive back or a wide receiver i
believe too right
yeah i mean it all works out how it's
supposed to i believe i'm right where
i'm supposed to be
uh but yeah it is kind of crazy looking
back and obviously i'm glad i believed
in myself and i think that's what's
what's gotten me this point uh so i'm
not gonna change that
okay i was told you were working out
with tom house's group
with john beck and you're working on
your mechanics
explain to me what you were working on
yeah their biggest thing got you know
got the opportunity
to work out um out there with those guys
and learned a ton and got to throw with
you know a ton of guys but their biggest
thing for me is just focusing on weight
shifts and using my lower body
not only when i need to um my biggest
thing was you know i didn't let my legs
get in the way of my throwing
uh but now it's it's using it to my
advantage if that makes sense
yeah and and i think when you get to
this next level everybody's got talent
but can you throw somebody
open uh you know the information that
comes in
from the sidelines into the huddle like
those are things that
can you how do you practice those things
yeah i mean learning is i think a skill
just being at north dakota state and
learning our offense i learned you know
how to learn and learn how to learn
football
so i think that'll you know huge
advantage for me as far as just coming
in and being able to learn a new offense
ask the right questions
um and be able to compete you know you
can't compete if you don't know what
you're doing
um but yeah i think that that time in
north carolina state was invaluable for
me
who gave you the best advice so far
uh my my offensive coordinator uh his
name is coach roll
um he's my offensive coordinator his
best piece of advice that you know he
says we say back and forth to each other
just show up early i'll work everyone
and make everyone around you better
where are you going to be tonight i'm in
cleveland
right now so i'm going to be in the
green room with family and spend some
time obviously
get to hang out with them today a little
bit um but yeah i'm excited for
obviously the opportunity but you're a
competitor
is is trevor lawrence better than you
i mean i i don't believe so but he's
gonna tell you the same exact thing and
every guy in strat class will tell you
the same exact thing uh he's super
talented obviously i think this draft
class
is gonna be really really special
especially at the quarterback position
yeah because you have to have confidence
in you like zach wilson
you think you're better than zach wilson
right yeah
we were just at breakfast this morning
and he'll tell you the same exactly
did you say to him at breakfast hey i'm
better than you
no i didn't but uh like i said he would
say the same exact thing okay here's a
really important question
and i hope you'll give it great thought
what are you wearing tonight
because this lasts forever when
when we talk about trey lance and we
show
we do a big feature on trey lance and
they'll show you with the commissioner
and what are you wearing tonight i can't
tell you
what color this is oh come on you're
you're not going north dakota state
colors
i'm not gonna tell you i gotta i gotta
leave you you know i i need you to
this this way i know if i don't tell you
you'll at least look it up to check me
out
you know okay i can guarantee that
you're gonna see it okay now i'm gonna
watch the draft i wasn't going to
but i'm going to tune in how long do i
have to watch before i
see you in your suit like how how long
do you think it is before you get up on
stage
you'll probably see it before the draft
starts i wouldn't mind oh oh no no then
i got to watch the
pre-show you didn't say that you said
the draft now
you might have to look on twitter or
something like that okay when the
commissioner calls your name
handshake hug bro hug
other chest bump
hey chest bump is still in in it's an
option
the chest bump is an option you know
what i'm thinking probably hug
that's more my my style because if you
take down the commissioner
yeah that might be an issue no no no no
no be
it'd be great like you're so excited
that if you did a chest bump with the
commissioner
knocked him down
legend might have planned something like
that no
all right let me see how you're doing as
a pitch man here because
peyton manning set the bar really high
on quarterbacks
you know being pitchman so let me hear
your pitch for old spice
yes i'm super excited and honestly proud
to be part of the old spice um
everything they're doing their
partnership with big brothers big
sisters of america
you know putting the spotlight on
mentorship and for me i know i wouldn't
be where i'm at today without
all the mentors in my life whether it
was coaches you know older players or
just people in the communities that i've
grown up in
um so their you know commitment to
helping guys in the younger generation
build confidence and reach their true
potential through mentorship is
something that i values and i think
that's why i'm so proud
to be partnered with an organization
like this and obviously you can check
out more at bigdraft21.com
and you look you know you wouldn't even
know you were reading that you delivered
it so
well but see that's just an inside
somebody who's on tv
i understand it trey see if i'm a
defensive back i'm reading your eyes
right now
and that's not good i might have i'm
gonna check you out
i have a jacket i like it
but i'm surprised you didn't have it on
your wristband like you're cheating
that's for next time all right hey good
luck
great story um make sure you hug
you know the family because they they
help get you there and
let them know how much they mean to you
as well because it's going to happen so
quickly and you're going to be going in
a million different directions but uh
good luck okay absolutely thank you so
much for having me
okay that's trey lance he doesn't know
where he's going
i don't know where he's going he didn't
lose a game as a starter at north dakota
state